the Acura Grand Prix at Long Beach goes
down this very weekend and in town
anytime it's an open invitation for you
anytime on phone but certainly when
you're in town great to see my buddy
Graham Rahal how are you great I'm good
thanks for having like a tradition
unlike any other you're in the town for
the long as you come in
speaking of tradition unlike any other
you're interesting the Masters just like
a huge they yeah okay yeah so a
tradition unlike any other is the
Masters right and a tradition unlike any
other here at the Rich Eisen show is not
just you appearing for the long beach
grand prix yeah but for us to turn to
Chris Brockman and ask him to try and
pronounce the name of somebody who's
leading a tournament and the gentleman
who is leading the tournament right now
I would love for you to take a shot
first
I am NOT talking about Justin Harding
yeah about this gentleman from Denmark
even I am did you the favor to decipher
which flag it is being 3-under it's my
computer for us you just let me describe
for you Graham and everyone at home the
letter J is the second letter of the
name before it it's a consonant and then
J that's tough I begin with then there's
two R's next to each other in two A's
next to each other there's it's just all
sorts of stuff happening it's an eye
chart okay so this is what I'm currently
3-yard the Masters I got the first name
his name's Lucas Lucas Lucas Berger do
research should you how do you pronounce
his name B regard the area yeah that is
a good effort come on close yeah I'm
bored here come on regard in regards
this regards just or tiara or guy or
regard there's two A's in a row
that's a tradition unlike any other how
about Justin
I got that what's your golf game like my
golf game is pretty good what is it
Staceyann I think I'm like for
handicapped dude okay all right
seriously out of all people in the world
out of all people in the world who gives
me crap from my alma mater because he's
an Ohio State yeah you're the one that I
I don't mind it from the most because
you're so nice
and then my games not that poor handicap
well good it's the same thing like
you're just too damn you you know like
golf golf is uh golf's like my one thing
when racing what you know when when the
races get all busy and we're kind of
carried away yes golf's like the perfect
thing for me to do to go and kind of get
away from it when I was a little kid my
dad who's supposed to be with us today
unfortunately is learning that wasn't
going through old driver problems having
back issues but right he taught he said
to me hey you need to learn play golf
because someday golf is gonna be a great
way for you to do business and I was
literally like six years old and I'm
like I don't even know what you mean
what is business I have no means going
potty but it has been super beneficial
I've had a lot of fun played won the
Honda Classic pro-am this year for our
44th time out there yeah in Florida
which is awesome so I love it it's like
my one way to kind of get away and some
time we'll go swing I'd love to I mean
you gotta understand I'm a for handicap
but I can also like it can go both ways
I mean I can play well and then by the
way some days just gotta stop just stop
there just gotta click your handicap I
couldn't even begin
I mean of my if my candy cap ever got
down to 14 it would be a great day okay
so don't worry okay I mean I'm I get out
there I work real hard so what I do for
a living yes I work real hard for living
and I got a little bit more than I wish
I could too but that's okay who's the
best player on your on your circuit oh
if there was a competition amongst
Tigers for sure me because literally
doesn't like two of us that play it's
kind of weird not a lot of guys not a
lot of guys play I think the only other
guy that I know that like actively
enjoys it as maybe like
max Chilton but aside from that there's
not there's not many because in you know
on the Thursday before the Indy 500 so
may 23rd we host our annual foundation
golf event that my wife Courtney and I
do and I've tried to get them all to
come and participate and be a part of it
and really just none of them none of
them play so that's it's not that hard
of a competition unfortunately I just
didn't know okay good most are pretty
stuck in driving there's a lot of Europe
there is a lot but yeah they're just not
that active in it okay so you can take
them down to very good
are you aware that he's being driven
around in in Acura NSX
I am Acura NSX in my old pal Elio is
taking you
Castroneves talked about a Dancing with
the Stars you know it's a song he's a
legend dancing with stars legend won it
a couple times he's he's won here before
I think something good hands but I well
I mean yeah it's not yeah that wasn't a
good feel better about myself exactly
what you want to crash no no I don't
want to vomit or like oh I'm getting off
a roller coaster no the NSX is silky
smooth so you'll be fine better it would
be a lot smoother than a two seater
right because to CRI it's pretty rough
well you did that with Andrew yeah you
did it I did it we were in you do inches
away from a concrete wall and you'll all
due respect to the legend that is Mario
Andretti 75 year old man is about an
hour it was very scary yeah so the NSX
will be a much more pleasant yeah you're
still gonna be inches away but it will
be a little bit it's gonna be like no
matter we can go out and drive
absolutely anything and you're gonna
you're gonna push it to the limit so is
this Bronco watch how wide his eyes get
his eyes get the size of saucers man so
you know and so when I saw the hold your
head
terrified the next year I did it and I'm
like one thing I am NOT gonna do is get
wide-eyed not gonna do it I think I put
a dark-colored visor on see that is the
coolest thing you know the the Honda
fastest seating sports they do it at the
start of every race so somebody gets to
go out and do that but also the
two-seater rides it's one of the things
IndyCar racing does that like you know
even fans can come and like buy a
two-seater ride and go out and do it and
that's cool I think it's like the
greatest way to connect to like what we
do or give them the best sensation right
clearly it's a little different but at a
place like Long Beach or you know
mid-ohio which is my home track is
awesome you know you get to experience
all the elevation and everything really
really cool so driving a street car is a
totally different animal
right it's a different animal but you
can push it pretty hard and the one
thing I know about Elio because I was
his teammate I drove the Acura a sports
car which will be here racing obviously
the Indy cars of the the main event
one thing I know about Elio because we
shared a car together last year he
pushes hard really hard so don't so
you'll have a great time breakfast or
lunch what would you say what should his
pre-race plan be I mean I would simplify
your eating like you'll be fine that
wouldn't eat anything that's gonna like
maybe okay you know don't go I have
anything spicy no no like spicy burrito
for breakfast no no no he doesn't do
that very much I see you you you pop
almonds that's pretty bland yeah you
okay good all right you'll be good oh
you know that's like when I win a
fighter fighter jet they're like hey you
know just don't just just don't eat very
much you know keep it pretty simple it
worked
what are you eat before a race yeah
normally like before actual race day
probably pasta and chicken just grilled
chicken pasta I was looking around I was
heavy otherwise looking around for food
logos on your shirt so you could just
drop a little little I don't have any
anymore now you know Steak and Shake
thing kind of came to an end two years
ago something connected over that we did
but you know we first connect those days
are gone we had each other at Steak and
Shake I still have
I still have my steak and shake card so
if you need to borrow that money good oh
gosh let's get to it here Graham Rahal
in the Rich Eisen show okay do you know
who I watched the Super Bowl behind I
don't know okay
so I go to the Super Bowl with you
watched directly behind him no but you
guys I was directly behind him it was in
the commissioner's suite at this year's
Super Bowl and the lovely new digs at
the Atlanta Falcons have and because
we're both Honda people I won't say the
name of the stadium so we're in there
yeah and it's assigned seating yeah so
there's two rows of comfy you know
chairs yeah and then there's the third
row of bar seating
chairs so everyone can see I'm in the
bar seat chair in the back and I look
who's directly in front of me Hamilton
know who would be the guy would want to
least want to watch the game with oh oh
urban urban life what'd he say to you
well I mean he has to know you're Dyer
Michigan the dude i sat on the draft I
said you're unfamiliar he was on the NFL
Network draft coverage in Chicago the
second night of the draft the night that
Ohio State set the record for most
players drafted from a single school
over the first three rounds of any draft
ever I broadcast online I was eating
copious amounts of figurative poop
sandwiches that's on that chassis over
and my professionalism unwavering
unwavering unwavering but you're
disappointed deep down furious okay I
don't show those things in the same way
you get behind the wheel of a car you
handled everything right you're cool as
a cucumber you have to yeah that's the
way I otherwise you you know things can
can get shaky so I saw him there and I
first thing I went up to the
Commissioner Roger Goodell I went up the
Commissioner I'm like look I know you're
a busy man you're not in charge of the
seating chart what did I do something
wrong like did I piss you off what the
hell did
how do I end up response was to laugh
and just basically sit down and watch
the Superbowl yeah exactly
and so her here comes her band Meyer he
says hi to me I say hi to him
and he's a Chatty Cathy he just wanted
to talk ball the whole time
really oh yeah he's into the game asking
me some thoughts at some point one point
though I've never said this on the air
Chris but I'll say it here for though he
turns around he goes you know your
program he just lets it trail off like
that I'm like I know so you know it's
awkward though but you know it's awkward
today what today
Ohio State gets their gold pants and
there are two coaches in that room yes
they were beaten last year Madison and
Washington right front we're gonna be
our staff watching all these people get
there no what do you mean they don't get
their pants they get gold pants they get
like pants that are actually going you
know the gold pants the necklace a
little like it's not like 34 by 30 pants
that they get 20 years they should I
mean the size need to get a little bit
bigger than this tiny little thing that
it's historically been why pants don't
know care gram I think these things are
all trinkets they are all just
insignificant pieces of gold yeah things
you trade their tattoos but it was funny
with urban he was just he was he was
great
he's a good guy some would beg to just
raise their hand talk about something
because it you know he was he couldn't
have been more gracious there were some
kids that were in there Keefe said hello
to all of them you know I don't know if
you saw the video of the the trainer
from Clemson who got tickets to the
Super Bowl and see that yeah he was
there and he wanted
urban a hug urban gave him a hug he was
he was like America's Sweetheart walking
around there yeah he's retired he gazed
on a fox he's he's done but he's all he
wanted to do is just talk ball and he
said that Haskins he's like that kid can
throw he's good now I know I'm not
telling it tells us yeah but like it
struck me he's like that's the best
thrower he's ever he said well why not
when when asked is was a was a freshman
Tim May from the Columbus Dispatch I've
known Tim forever Tim said to me like
this kids the best quarterback Ohio
State's ever had I was like but he's not
even starting he goes you just wait
right just wait he's gonna like he's
gonna have to take his time he's gonna
have to earn his stripes but this kid
yes throw a football did you hear who
I'm sure you didn't because you were too
busy being you and doing your stuff and
travel around the country Trent Dilfer
was on our show he repeated what he said
into his Sports Illustrated who Haskins
reminds him of or has the attributes of
he called him Tom Brady ish it's what he
said because of the the the the way that
he throws the way that he can move
around and the different types of throws
that he can make he just said it looks
like Brady well he's good that's what he
said I don't want to talk about Brady
that much why is that um well I will
tell you this and this year I actually
talk about Tom Brady actually rooted for
Tom Brady in the Super Bowl this year
mhm and why did I do that I did that
because like you just talked about Urban
Meyer and the way everybody wants to
continuously like knock greatness hmm I
finally decided like Tom Brady is great
Bill Belichick and only just 6-3
ahlstrom
no like I just didn't want to I don't
know I was one of those guys like I'm
like nah he's Michigan guy can't do this
know that but then eventually you got to
be like no you have to reward and like
accept and just really appreciate just
great night it's just I mean just got a
little best you take a look at Brady and
then you just add tupa to Tomczak to
Herbstreit to gram wait a minute I'm not
done giving you add on some Barrett you
add on some Smith
Easter I'm just trying to name all the
Ohio State quarterback had one on top of
the other after the other after the
other after the other and we're still
waiting around
we're still waiting around for somebody
even maybe he's just approached me
asking Korona maybe he just approached
the corona by the way great name great
name of an album I think there was an
album at Jimmy Buffett Buffett out so
all right you know and all in all
seriousness though yeah I appreciate you
coming around on Tom yeah yeah yeah on
behalf of although just finish up you've
got the gold pants thing so it started
back in 1934 full rancis Schmidt took
over for Ohio State prior to that point
Michigan has dominated the series Ohio
State had just six wins told you told
cyclical and two times two ties in 30
games from 1897 to 1933 Francis Schmidt
took over after a run at TCU and they
asked him about how he's how's he gonna
be Michigan and I he came up with the
famous quote be fine it's awesome they
put their pants on one leg at a time
just like the rest of us he that's the
first guy to drop that cliche yeah he is
generate craze Ohio stay baby and then
they won the game in 1934 and they gave
out gold pins in the shape of pants to
everyone how about that and there it
began and there it began who's the coach
who first came up with I don't have a
crystal ball who's the first coach you
came up with it is what it is I don't
know the first coach to come up with I'm
only talking about the guys who are here
they beat Michigan 38 telling you the
first coach to ever come up with the
phrase they put their pants on one leg
at a time just like us
little dude Michigan guys back then put
their pants on two legs at a time popped
right in the pants hey man good to see
you go crush it
take him down man we're gonna try come
all down we're gonna try we're looking
forward to having you out there excited
to be just the fourth race of the
season corrects north fourth race of the
year okay accurate took over as a title
sponsor this year which is awesome
excellent and our teams coming off a win
last week mm-hmm wasn't me but my
teammate we a little issue with our car
we started one - its first time we
locked up the front row since like 2003
is a team or Chisholm for something like
that so we got a little momentum on our
sides and we're we're looking forward to
it I think we should be we should be
pretty strong
well I root for you in the in the
biggest way you know that I hope so I do
thank you you are you're one of my
favorites and one of these days you have
to come all man look at that photo of
day what photo does that mean in there
Ohio State and I have something for that
but one of these days you have to
actually come to the race to the long
beach I mean yeah I know you came and
took a two-seater ride we got a coming
real deal and the Indy 500
well that is it's cool Indy 500 you like
it here we can go to Steak and Shake and
you know you don't defeat me that's
gonna make it all happen okay
okay I need a I need a VIP tour though
man you know you always say like a
Letterman's your guy my guy he's my idol
he was there last week your guarantee me
access to Dave yeah he still has a huge
just got a huge beard huge beard like
you came out of the the Ecuador embassy
yeah okay fantastic good to see you sir
thank you sir good luck to you man thank
you to see you great to see you Graham
Rahal watch it Sunday it's gonna be on
NBCSN 4:30 p.m. Eastern Time the Acura
Grand Prix at Long Beach good luck to
Castroneves make sure he gets to get to
sleep tonight one o'clock tomorrow at
Graham rail light at Graham Rahal on
Twitter and Instagram for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app